craving a career upgrade subscribe like
and comment
below dive into the link in the
description to FastTrack your Ambitions
whether you're making a switch or aiming
higher simply learn has your
back in the fastpac world of it General
management takes on unique character
it's a blend of overseeing the technical
complexities of projects and products
while keeping a firm grip on the
business side of things a professional
in general management adapts to the
rapid pace of technological change and
keeps the organization competitive on
one hand and on the other hand he needs
to balance the needs of different
stakeholders from developers to
Executives within a complex it landscape
defining and tracking success metrics
for IT projects and initiatives Beyond
pure technical performance is no easy
job and not something you can Master
overnight that's one of the many reasons
to get six figure salaries and a range
of prom minent career prospects the
general manager career options brims
with a promising future the it Market
expects at least 6% job growth by 2028
solving the tales of numbers we can
expect an average of 1ak 189,000 vacant
positions by 2028 wages keep Pace
climbing 4% in 5 years a general manager
in India is paid an average salary of a
whooping 35 lakhs to 40 lakhs INR in
America an executive general manager can
expect an average salary of $80,000 to
$100,000 annually some of the top
recruiters of certified executive
general managers are Accenture IBM Tata
consultancy services that is TCS
cognizant enosis vippro deoy Cap Gemini
Microsoft and Amazon web services and
many more to grab such great
opportunities a certification can have a
significant impact the executive
certificate program in general
management from IM indor is a beacon
in the sea of options get on a journey
to professional growth with simply
learns executive certificate program in
general management from IM indor ranked
at sixth position in nirf 2021 this
tailor made program perfectly suits
current it standards I am Andor has been
the leader in management education
interfacing with industry government and
psus this course equips you with
strategic leadership skills and has the
potential to elevate your career
prospects it unlocks higher earning
potential in India USA and the rest of
the world to begin with we'll have a
brief induction session for the IM Ando
General Management program to explore
everything about this online executive
program and Kickstart your general
management Journey up next we have
Foundations of Management for a thorough
introduction to management practices via
the lenses of four important disciplines
accounting Finance marketing and
organization behavior following that we
enter the economics for business to
understand basic economic Concepts like
elasticity demand and Supply equilibrium
and Industrial laws uphead we will deal
with accounting and financial management
to learn how accounting principles are
used to elevate and communicate a
company financial position to external
stakeholders and how to interpret
Financial reports to make business
decisions next we have Ops and SCM to
learn how products and services are
developed created purchased sold and
offered to clients in the manufacturing
and service industry using problem
solving strategies decision- making and
critical thinking later we will dive
into marketing management to help you
understand the most important marketing
strategies including market research
competitor analysis segmentation to 5c
framework and many more following that
we will learn everything about HR to
assist you how to connect with and
engage staff for improved performance
output and how to manage staff
performance utilizing a variety of
compensation and reward management
techniques then moving further business
analytics is where you learn General
manage management course emphasizes
using three different types of analytics
descriptive predictive and prospective
analytics next ahead management and
Leadership will teach you the
fundamentals of effective team
leadership how to build and manage
successful teams and how to encourage a
creative workplace culture furthermore
the business strategy will help you
learn the fundamentals theories and
Frameworks such as 5c Force analysis
position strategies Pest and SWAT
analysis next up you will learn design
thinking a strategic tool to create new
product Services understand how to adopt
design thinking in a company and the
difference between system thinking
complimentary mindsets and design
thinking leading the program we have
digital disruption and Innovation to
learn the undying themes that successful
digital disruptors employ discover the
fundamentals of business models the 4 I
framework pricing schemes the digital
supply chain digital transformation and
many more key ideas finally we will deal
with Capstone project in the general
management Capstone project that will
help you you put the knowledge you have
learned in this program to use by
applying it to numerous sectors and the
cherry on top is generative AI Master
Class you can attend this live online
immersive master class on generative AI
designed to empower participants with
the Knowledge and Skills to harness its
incredible potential although we have
named a few this executive certificate
program in general management will cover
many more topics and Concepts well then
what else can you expect from this
program I am Jo Pro memberships of 6
months for free resume building
assistance to create a powerful resume
Spotlight on IM jobs for highlighting
your profile to recruiters this program
caters to working professionals from
various Industries and backgrounds the
diversity of our students adds richness
to class discussions and interactions so
what are you waiting for don't miss this
golden opportunity to take your career
to the next level and roll in our
executive certificate program in general
management today to become a certified
executive Eng General management our
next batch starts soon for more details
check the link in the description
box staying ahead in your career
requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply Lear YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to ner up and get certified click
here